uh uh there are worrying statistics
across a number of countries eu leaders
um have arrived in brussels this morning
for a summit no surprise to learn uh
that kovid is very much top of the
agenda the president of the european
commissioner of underlying saying
yesterday that omicron is expected to be
the dominant variant across the eu block
by mid
january so they're looking at measures
to try and control that and some of the
countries have got their eye very much
on the uk because of the rise in figures
there in fact we understand that the
prime minister's office in france will
later today announce greater
restrictions on people going to france
from the uk uh reducing the validity of
pcr tests from what is currently 48
hours to 24 hours other countries
bringing in um significant measures for
example italy this week
has insisted on people getting negative
covid tests before they arrive and that
is an issue for the eu because what they
want to press home today is that there
should be a sort of continuity a unified
approach and that countries shouldn't
act unilaterally but some of them are of
course doing that now vaccines are very
much on the minds of all of the uh eu
leaders ursula von delight said that the
eu is in a good position having
vaccinated something like 66
of its population but there are concerns
while some countries like portugal and
spain have immunized the vast majority
of their residents uh places like
bulgaria only 27 so they will be looking
at the concern particularly about
omicron today although delta for the
moment still the dominant variant